that title might be a little bit over
the top but in this video I will let you
know why this laptop is probably the
best bang for the buck laptop for
photographers and also why I wouldn't
buy this old laptop for serious video
editors and instead suggest a different
spec model that makes a lot more sense
as always we have our recommendations
linked in the video description below if
you guys buy through those links to help
support our channel and helps us make
more videos like this one so if you guys
buy through those we would HIGHLY
appreciate it thank you after a long
wait we finally have does latest version
of its XPS 15 laptop the 7590 which
looks practically identical on the
outside but as some big improvements and
updates on the inside and a brand new
OLED display which is gorgeous but
there's one thing that really bugs me
about this laptop that will really
matter for some of you but more on that
in just a bit just like last year its
encased in an aluminium shell that looks
and feels great compared to many other
Windows laptops the display has very
thin and great-looking bezels but the
webcam and quad mic quality is quite
poor along with that we don't have
Windows hello authentication which we
absolutely love but the power button
doubles as a fingerprint scanner the
keyboard feels pretty decent for a
Windows laptop with a good amount of
travel featuring two levels of
backlighting typing is pretty
comfortable but we do wish the keys were
a bit wider as before build quality is
really solid and it doesn't flex like
many other Windows laptops do and even
though the soft coating doesn't feel as
premium as an all-aluminum design it
feels really nice to the touch one thing
that we can complain about is that
there's no notch in the front to help
you open it up so you kind of have to
jam your fingernail in there and kind of
pull it open and the hinge is also
pretty stiff so it's hard to open with
one hand the trackpad is also pretty
decent for a Windows laptop it used to
be one of the best but other brands have
really stepped up their game recently so
now it's about average as far as port
selection we have a headphone mic combo
jack full size HDMI 2 USBS a single
Thunder both 3 ports and thankfully a
full size SD card slot Dell really got
it right on the port's that they offer
with both standard USB supporting full
10 gigabit per second and the HDMI being
version 2.0 for full 4k 60
the ports and the SD card is a UHS to
slot which really speeds up transfers
with newer cards charging is done
through a barrel plug and a 130 watt
power brick but thankfully you can also
use you SVC but do you know that that
will be slower my only disappointment
and it's a big one is that there is just
one fundable three port I understand if
this was a budget machine but at almost
2700 dollars this 15 ish machine should
at least have to heck even the $1200 XPS
13 has to Thunderbolt three ports and
another USB C alright let's move on to
the laptop itself which is a huge by any
means coming in at 4.5 pounds but
putting it next to a 15-inch razor or
MacBook Pro and it's definitely on the
chunkier side but with the extra size
and weight comes a lot of conveniences
taking off the back panel we're greeted
with a slotted nvme SSD Wi-Fi card and
even RAM meaning that if you buy a lower
end option you can very easily swap a 2
to 16 gigabyte RAM sticks for only a
hundred and twenty two dollars which
I'll leave a link for down in the
description below and even up to 64
gigabytes of total RAM which is rare in
a laptop like this this is very
refreshing because many laptops are now
coming with solder DRAM and SSDs with
this one you can extend its life by
upgrading it in a few years and swapping
out the battery which is also very easy
and fairly inexpensive to do the SSDs
are on the slow side for nvme but the
built-in Wi-Fi chip is quite good one
thing that still disappoints us
year-over-year is the speaker quality
and this time it almost seems like it's
worse than before the volume is just ok
but it almost seems like the mids are
missing and the bass just sounds like
little popping sounds here's a
comparison to my macbook pro
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a few years ago these types of speakers
were the norm but many Windows laptops
have been making big improvements I just
reviewed a tiny 2.6 pound Lenovo and
that ultrabook had better sounding
speakers than this thing and even Dells
own 13-inch XPS has 5 watts of speakers
with the larger 15-inch coming in with
just 4 watt speakers Dell please fix
this on the plus side the battery is
quite large at 97 watt hours and unlike
last year we no longer have a big dip in
performance when we unplug it from the
wall it's still there but it's minimal
before we touch on performance let's
first talk about the display we have a
non touch 4k olla display with 500 nits
of brightness I always thought the
MacBooks displays were amazing but
putting that 500 nits DCI p3 LCD
side-by-side windows OLED really made it
look mediocre if you want to watch 4k
videos on this thing Wow does it look
good it's just a shame that the speakers
can't keep up out of the box the colors
were too saturated and that's what the
cinema mode turned off which pushes
saturation even further so if you want
to work with editing images or video I
would highly suggest a display
calibrator I will link my suggestion
down in the video description below I
was a bit worried about color accuracy
since Linus tech tips OLED razor had a
huge color ship from maxing out the
brightness but after calibrating my
spider rated the display at 100% srgb
and 98% Adobe RGB what the brightness
turned all the way up the model that he
was reviewing went up to 600 nits of
brightness and going down just one notch
on the brightness improved color
accuracy by over 30% but being that the
XPS Max is out of 500 nits it seems to
avoid these issues but I would still
calibrate it and keep the brightness at
the same level if you're doing color
accurate work overall this display is
gorgeous but that issue with color shift
and also the potential for burnin will
push some people away but thankfully
there's also an option for a standard 4k
LCD which is now also 500 nits and has a
100% Adobe RGB color accuracy as well as
touch operation I'll comment on that
screen and a different better set up in
just a bit
finally let's get to performance on the
inside is an Intel Core i 9 a core CPU
rated at two point four to five
gigahertz though I couldn't get it to
run higher than 4.7 gigahertz even below
50 degrees Celsius and single cord tasks
pushing all cores to the limit using
Cinebench r20 we got a beastly score of
3381
under full load the fans are quite loud
louder than a 8 core MacBook Pro but
keep the CPU 2 degrees Celsius cooler
but at a still high 92 degrees Celsius
and the i9 runs at 100 megahertz higher
then in the MacBook Pro not a big
difference but it's there speaking of
fans the stock fan curve is annoying
with the fans sometimes even kicking up
with the machine just sitting there
plugged in in too often when just
browsing the web but that can be
adjusted in software for photo editors
the excellent display paired with that 8
core CPU an SD card reader along with a
variety of ports and good build quality
makes this one of if not the best bang
for the buck photo editing laptops the
performance is ever so slightly better
than an 8 core MacBook Pro as you can
see by our tests but coming in at about
750 large cheaper and with a better
display of course the MacBook has better
speakers trackpad and SSD and is also
slimmer and lighter but it's not
upgradeable and has weaker graphics that
don't really matter for photo editing on
the windows side for this price range
you're either gonna skimp on build
quality display quality or get a 6 core
CPU instead of an 8 core often a mix of
those so if you really need a powerful
CPU with a great screen in this price
range
the 7590 is likely your best choice now
the tables turn once we get into video
editing mainly because of the Nvidia
1650 graphics I understand if the base
option paired with the 6 core was a 1650
but even for the top align model we
can't get anything better like we can
with other brands
now the 1650 isn't terrible and it's a
decent upgrade from last year but paired
with a powerful 8 quart eye 9 graphics
it's now at the bottleneck for video
editing in the last year or so there's
been great strides in GPU acceleration
and having a powerful GPU matters more
than ever before on the Mac side Apple
has been improving efficiency with a
metal API
even though the XPS has more powerful
graphics rendering time for a 5 minute
4k project with the fax took almost 6
minutes compared to four and a half
minutes and the playback is actually
smoother on the MacBook Pro as well
my MSI p75 which is a similarly priced
laptop but with worse build quality and
display quality finished the same
project in 3 minutes and 52 seconds even
though it has a slightly slower 2.3
gigahertz eye 9 a core processor the
difference is in the graphics with the
RT X 27 t allowing it to perform much
better
the 1650 is just too weak of a GPU to
pair with this eight core and as time
goes on graphics will be used even more
so it's a shame that with this great
laptop even though the high spec we
don't have the option to get a better
GPU testing a five-minute graded project
using raw video from the C 200 the XPS
is now closer to the MacBook Pro since
this footage is more CPU intensive but
our MSI is still ahead at 30 minutes and
2 seconds if you're a serious video
editor and want an 8 core we would
highly recommend looking elsewhere with
at least an RT X 2060 and better
speakers since trying to work with the
sound using the built-in speakers is
really kind of a nightmare
dell also sells a 2099 dollar model
which has the same Nvidia 1650 graphics
card but with a 6 core processor which
is a much better pairing and in many
cases like video editing gaming and
other GPU intensive uses the actual
performance will be exactly the same
that spec still comes with a one
terabyte SSD but only with 16 gigabytes
of RAM but you can easily change that
and very affordably upgrade it to 32
gigabytes you won't get OLED but it's
still a 4k display that is very colored
accurate so even though I wouldn't
recommend the 8 core OLED XPS 15 for
serious video editors if you're somebody
that doesn't need the latest and
greatest bleeding-edge in terms of
performance the 6 core non OLED model is
a great bang for the buck
overall the Dell XPS 15 isn't perfect
and we wish that they would have made
more external changes like adding more
Thunderbolt 3 ports windows hello and
better speakers it's still a fantastic
all-around value especially for those
that really need to have a good
BPU and not to forget this laptop is
still fairly upgradable down the line
where much of the competition isn't
thank you guys for watching this has
been max with Max tech if you guys want
to see more videos like this one click
that little circle above and then down
below hit the notification bell if you
want to be notified when we post new
videos and if you guys want to see a
comparison between the Dell XPS and the
MacBook Pro you guys can click them
right over there I will see you guys in
the next video
[Music]